mi motivación para hacer esta serie de
vídeos acerca del sistema de reserva de
banca fraccionaria no es que quiera ser
así algún cambio revolucionario o pues
tampoco es que creo que si seguimos en
este sistema del mundo se va a acabar lo
único que quiero es que aclaremos un
poquito los pensamientos colectivos que
tenemos al respecto acerca de qué es y
cuáles son sus debilidades vaya es el
sistema en el que estamos y por esta
razón muchas veces se piensa como si
fuera el único sistema con el cual pues
podría funcionar la banca claro ahorita
la mayoría de los bancos están
funcionando con este sistema sin embargo
esta estructura solo ha estado así
funcionando por digamos unos 100 años y
no es la única forma de hacer banca como
ya vimos en vídeos pasados incluso tiene
algunas debilidades déjame volverlas a
mencionar para acordarnos la primera la
primera y es algo que puede causar
incomodidad a muchas personas es esta
naturaleza insincera de la reserva
fraccionaria
y sincera
la cosa era que le decía a alguien mira
puedes sacar todo tu dinero cuando
quieras cuando en realidad eso no era
cierto puedes sacar todo el dinero
siempre y cuando menos del 10% de las
personas quieran su dinero a la vez esto
ya de entrada es una cosa super incómoda
pero esta cosa por si mismas no es
suficiente para decir pues que todo el
sistema está echado a perder el problema
es que esta mitad verdad lleva el
concepto de un retiro vacío
todo el mundo tiene derecho a obtener
todo su dinero de regreso en un día o
quizás en una hora pero la verdad es que
no todas las personas pueden obtener su
dinero de regreso esto lleva a una
inconsistencia algunas personas no
pueden retirar su dinero y esto podría
causar pánico podría llevar a un pánico
generalizado esto está súper mal verdad
es una situación muy grave para todo el
sistema bancario no queremos un sistema
financiero que sea inestable sistema
financiero inestable
financiero inestable para arreglar este
problema de los retiros masivos pues
básicamente se inventaron dos remedios
uno es un prestamista de último recurso
de último recurso que usualmente es el
banco de la reserva y probablemente más
importante tenemos un seguro bancario
por ejemplo en eeuu es el seguro de la
fdic
seguro de la fed hice como platicaba en
el vídeo pasado el principal problema
que veo con la fdc es que básicamente le
da a todos los bancos la misma capacidad
de obtener porque puedes decir y
deposita tu dinero aquí está asegurado
entonces esencialmente es un subsidio
federal
subsidio federal
para todos los bancos para todos los
bancos y vaya por definición el hecho de
que la fcc ha tenido que ir varias veces
al congreso para pedir más dinero quiere
decir que estaba cobrando de menos y que
por tanto es un subsidio para los bancos
como a todos estos bancos la fed y se
les cobra casi lo mismo pero les da la
misma cobertura entonces se fomenta
tomar mucho riesgo se fomenta tomar
mucho riesgo
y mucho riesgo para esencialmente tener
más ganancia más ganancia como sucede
esto pues el costo de tomar prestado del
banco es el mismo o sea la gente
usualmente diría estás haciendo cosas
arriesgadas entonces me tienes que pagar
más interés para que yo quiera depositar
pero el banco dice no no estoy asegurado
por life dice como ese banco de allá de
la esquina el el banco conservador
entonces si tengo que pagar un poquito
más para que me dé estos depósitos pero
con eso puedo tomar riesgos bien grandes
subsidiados por el gobierno federal va
incluso con todos estos problemas me
podría decir pues que tiene o sea por
ejemplo los eeuu tienen un sistema de
banca de reserva fraccionaria y son así
la potencia económica mundial e incluso
hay muchos otros países países muy
desarrollados que usan el sistema de
banca de reserva fraccionaria entonces
por qué tanto lío con esta forma de
ingeniárnosla para arreglar el problema
pues ve la principal o sea creo que la
mejor forma de resolver este problema
pero antes déjame dejar muy claro que
cuando empecé a pensar en este problema
por todas las solicitudes que me
llegaron para pensar en él quiero dejar
muy claro que la primera vez que empecé
a pensar en el problema lo intenté hacer
de una manera
y neutral lo empecé a pensar muy bien
para no simplemente decir no pues está
súper malo soy una persona reaccionaria
y no me agrada para nada sin embargo
mientras más lo piensa uno se da cuenta
que hay algo que no cuadra aquí por
ejemplo cuando pensamos en cualquier
intermediario financiero cuál es su
propósito déjame dibujar un
intermediario financiero
intermediario financiero tienes
ahorradores
ahorradores ahora a ellos les gusta
meter su dinero en alguna bóveda para
que esté seguro a lo mejor les gusta
invertir pero no saben cómo hacerlo o su
dinero no tiene la escala suficiente
para invertirse bien y entonces el
intermediario financiero dice mira dame
tu dinero y voy a contratar a un montón
de personas listas para que inviertan su
dinero así en proyectos muy inteligentes
entonces estos son los ahorradores y del
otro lado hay proyectos de este lado
entonces aquí hay inversiones entonces
pues tu dinero se lo van a prestar a
algunos inversionistas en términos
generales por ejemplo si es un banco
comercial lo van a prestar si fuera un
capitalista de riesgo entonces lo va a
invertir directamente en compañías que
están iniciando pero a la idea de
cualquier intermediario financiero es la
misma para generar valor toman el dinero
de los inversionistas y lo invierten en
algún proyecto que tenga el rendimiento
positivo un proyecto que genere algún
retorno positivo pues un retorno
positivo luego lo que hacen es darle una
fracción de ese retorno a los
ahorradores
entonces le dan una fracción a los
ahorradores y el resto se lo quedan
ellos que si lo piensas pues no está mal
verdad realmente están ayudando a ubicar
el capital en proyectos buenos entonces
tienen una función útil para la sociedad
esto es una función
útil para la sociedad y entonces pues se
merecen tener sus trajes armani y tener
sus relojes rolex deja me pongo se
merecen entre comillas pero en cierto
sentido si están agregando valor a
nuestra economía bueno y ahora
necesitamos un sistema de reserva
fraccionaria para que puedan existir los
intermediarios financieros
pues la respuesta corta es no no
necesitamos reserva fraccionaria para
hacer esto de hecho hay muchos
intermediarios financieros que en pues
no participan en ningún modo en esto de
la reserva fraccionaria creo que los más
evidentes son los capitalistas de riesgo
digo no sé qué piensas acerca de ellos
de riesgo pero al menos con ellos las
cosas son muy honestas les dicen a sus
inversionistas que es como lo
equivalente a los depositantes en los
bancos les dicen mira no vas a poder
sacar tu dinero vamos a poder sacarlo
por
por no sé x años o bien van a decir mira
vamos a tomar tu dinero según lo
necesitemos y en ese momento ya no lo
puedes sacar como los fondos de capital
privado de hecho se parecen mucho los
capitalistas de riesgo con los de
capital privado solo que estos últimos
invierten en compañías que ya existen
también hay otros que se llaman fondos
de cobertura y ahí no encierran tu
dinero fondos de cobertura bueno no le
encierra la mayoría de tiempo si lo
encierran te lo van a decir entonces van
a ser muy honestos con sus
inversionistas y no es como que quiera
defenderlos pero si no encierran tu
dinero van a invertir en instrumentos
líquidos invierten en instrumentos
líquidos
bueno en realidad hay muchas personas en
esto de los fondos de cobertura hay
algunas que sí están agregando valor a
la sociedad y hay otras que no
probablemente la gran mayoría sólo está
intercambiando como en un tipo de juego
pero ahorita no me quiero meter en ese
debate ni defender al mundo de los
fondos de cobertura más bien la idea
principal era que para hacer una
institución financiera no necesitamos de
la noción de reserva fraccionaria
incluso aunque quieras hacer un banco
comercial por ejemplo yo podría recibir
depósitos
supongamos que tú vienes conmigo bueno
muchas personas vienen conmigo pero este
de aquí es tu depósito este es tu dinero
y supongamos que esto de aquí son 100
pesos son 100 pesos entonces lo que te
puedo decir es mira si tú quieres tu
dinero a la vista entonces no te voy a
dar ningún interés por él porque te
estoy ofreciendo el servicio de que lo
puedas sacar en el cajero y de que esté
seguro en mi bóveda incluso tal vez te
cobre una pequeña comisión por el dinero
a la vista si realmente quisiera obtener
interés por tu dinero entonces lo
tendrías que dejar pues cierta cantidad
de tiempo entonces lo que harías es
darme los 100 pesos
me das los 100 pesos
y entonces dices sabes que pues yo soy
un inversionista sofisticado y me
gustaría participar en los milagros del
capitalismo y entonces me dicen lo
siguiente sabes que de estos 100 pesos
yo sólo necesito 10 para pagar los
gastos de mi casa o de mi negocio
entonces de estos 10 pues al más una
cuenta de cheques y de eso no vas a
obtener nada de interés nada de interés
incluso tal vez tengas que pagar un
poquito y ahora si la otra porción el
otro tanto mientras más estés bien
mientras más tiempo estés dispuesto a
que se quede encerrado vas a obtener más
interés por él entonces no sé supongamos
que esto de aquí son diez dólares y me
dices sabes que voy a necesitar un
poquito del dinero dentro de un año
entonces aquí se hace un certificado de
depósito de un año le vamos a decir un
cd de un año y por este certificado el
banco te va a pagar un interés no sé
cómo del 2 o tal vez del 3% y finalmente
el resto del dinero puede que sea para
el retiro y lo necesites hasta dentro de
10 años entonces un cedé de 10 años y
como está encerrado por más tiempo
digamos que da 5 % vale entonces ahora
yo el banco comercial que no está
participando en la reserva fraccionaria
puedo decir mira este cuate tiene 10
pesos que quiere tener disponibles en
cualquier momento no voy a ganar interés
por esto solo le estoy dejando usar mi
infraestructura financiera entonces lo
voy a apartar lo pongo en mis bóvedas y
entonces lo puedes sacar del cajero
automático de ventanilla pero el resto
del dinero este de acá este sí que lo
puedo invertir entonces alguien me puede
decir oye sal bueno oye banco de sal
tengo un proyecto y para eso necesito
pedir prestado esta cantidad no sé
digamos 45 necesito pedir prestado 45
pesos por 8 años y yo digo va está bien
te lo puedo prestar porque este dinero
no lo voy a necesitar hasta dentro de 10
años entonces tomó esos 45 pesos y los
presto
hasta ahorita está muy bien todo verdad
porque si haces préstamos buenos
entonces vas a poder pagarle a tiempo a
este bonito y este monito sabe que hay
cierto riesgo al invertir en su dinero
aquí al dejar su dinero por diez años
contigo tiene que hacer su tarea e
investigar qué tanto le conviene hacer
este cedé de diez años como cualquier
inversionista verdad tiene que ver tú a
quién le haces préstamos pensar si es
muy riesgoso o no y sí sí lo es pedir
más interés o de plano no dejarte su
dinero muy bonito la naturalidad de la
oferta y la demanda o bien la
naturalidad de la retroalimentación del
sistema capitalista entra en juego vale
entonces la moraleja está clara puedes
hacer un montón de instituciones
financieras sin necesidad de que existe
el sistema de reserva de banca
fraccionaria siguiente pregunta ok ya
podemos correr un sistema financiero sin
reserva fraccionaria pero realmente qué
es lo malo de la reserva fraccionaria
que permite para esto déjame repasar la
curva de rendimiento
la curva de rendimiento no es nada muy
sofisticado simplemente es una gráfica
de cuánto interés pagas por ciertos
periodos de tiempo o cuánto interés
puedes obtener
entonces supongamos que esta es la curva
de rendimiento y por acá tenemos
préstamos de una noche así nomás por un
día pues por aquí están los préstamos a
un año y estos de acá son los préstamos
a diez años
puede haber muchas duraciones
simplemente es cuánto tiempo prestas tu
dinero ahora si le haces un préstamo al
gobierno que podemos pensar que es el
préstamo más seguro que puedes hacer
entonces no sé digamos que al gobierno
por un día estás dispuesto a cobrarle 1%
por un año pues sin el dinero ya está
encerrado entonces lo acepto por 2 por
ciento y a 10 años por 5 por ciento
entonces la curva de rendimiento se
vería algo así déjame dibujarla mejor
así la curva de rendimiento suele verse
así hacia arriba no siempre se ve así
pero pero casi siempre ok entonces esa
es la curva de rendimiento digamos para
pagarés para pagarés federales
bien entonces un día 1 % un año bueno
parece más como 3% y para 10 años
digamos 5% claro estos no son los
valores reales pero solo es para que te
hagas una idea este es para pagarés
federales que son los préstamos más
seguros ahora vamos a inversiones con
compañías buenas no sé digamos con bimbo
si con bimbo o tal vez con cocacola con
estas compañías voy a querer más
rendimiento pues no son tan seguras como
el gobierno federal pero igual su curva
de rendimiento se ve muy parecida se ve
algo así aquí en la gráfica hay algo de
rendimiento adicional porque estas
compañías aunque sean muy buenas
compañías son más riesgosas que el
gobierno federal pero su curva de todas
formas se ve hacia arriba y finalmente
tenemos los cuates que se arriesgan un
buen cada compañía tiene su propia curva
de rendimiento pero bueno pensemos que
hacemos un portafolio de compañías
riesgosas y entonces su curva de
rendimiento se vería así
fíjate que está muy alta pero tiene
sentido si llega un cuate que dice que
quiere invertir en biotecnologías pues
le voy a cobrar mucho más interés porque
pues no sé si va a estar por acá digamos
aquí en cinco años
bueno este es el repaso de la curva de
rendimiento pero quería mostrarte lo
para enseñarte como las reservas
fraccionarias permiten que los bancos se
aprovechen de la curva de rendimiento
sin realmente agregar ningún valor a la
sociedad fíjate que es muy distinto a lo
de acá arriba donde una institución
financiera debe de agregar valor a la
sociedad pero lo que estás permitiendo
con el sistema bancario de reserva
fraccionaria es que los bancos reciban
depósitos
esto que te voy a contar no solo pasa
con la reserva fraccionaria pasa en
otros lugares pero bueno reciben
depósitos que vaya son depósitos
exigibles no básicamente son préstamos
que le hicieron sus depositantes son
prácticamente préstamos exigibles a la
vista
préstamos exigibles a la vista sí pues
básicamente cuando dejas dinero en un
banco les estás haciendo un préstamo y
si pasa una hora y no retiras ese
préstamo es esencialmente como si
renovarán el préstamo esto se sigue
haciendo continuamente es la forma más
instantánea de prestar la misma idea
cada día que no lo sacas se renueve el
préstamo osea puedes imaginarte un mundo
en donde cada año se renueva un préstamo
si no sacas el dinero pero con el dinero
a la vista es como si se renovará cada
segundo bueno entonces los bancos pueden
pedir prestado en este punto de la curva
de rendimiento porque claro o sea pueden
pagarle a la gente una tasa de interés
muy bajo vaya incluso aunque estén
haciendo cosas muy arriesgadas como
prestarle al cuate de biotecnología
justo porque el seguro de la fdic hace
que la gente crea en ellos como si
fueran el gobierno federal porque éste
lo respalda entonces eso baja su costo
de tomar prestado toman prestado acá
abajo pero eso lo que les permite lo que
les permite es prestar dinero
prestar dinero por duración es más
largas digamos de diez años el dinero se
queda encerrado bueno se pagan pero el
dinero se queda encerrado por diez años
este de acá tal vez es de cinco años y
no solo eso sino que además se lo pueden
hacer a los proyectos más riesgosos o
sea pueden pedir prestado aquí que es lo
que le pagan a los depositantes como el
1% y luego simplemente pueden invertirlo
si así lo quieren digamos en pagarés
federales o en bonos de compañías con
buena reputación como bimbo sabritas y
obtener un montón de interés más un
montón de interés más y la verdad uno no
necesita ser genio para darse cuenta que
vamos a obtener más interés acá que de
este lado pero la única razón por la
cual los bancos lo pueden hacer es por
esta garantía implícita más bien
explícita que les da la fcc de la fdc
entonces este seguro de la fcc es
básicamente lo que hace que la gente se
pueda desprender de su dinero en este
punto de la curva de rendimiento una vez
que el banco ya tiene ese dinero
entonces puede ir invertirlo de este
lado de la curva de rendimiento y tener
una ganancia por la diferencia ganan 5%
por el dinero pero solo pagan un 1%
dónde está el valor para la sociedad yo
podría hacer esto pero no soy una
entidad certificada por life dice vayan
también estos depositantes les
encantaría poder prestar a 5 % pero no
pueden porque la fs no los asegura en
caso de pérdidas entonces básicamente mi
punto es que el sistema de banca de
reserva fraccionaria y todo tuvo que ver
con la reserva fraccionaria es que este
sistema le permite a los bancos hacer
arbitraje sobre la curva de rendimiento
les permite tomar prestado en un extremo
prestarlo en el otro extremo y ganar en
la diferencia la verdad número 1 esto no
agrega nada de valor a la sociedad no
necesitas una maestría especializada
para que se te ocurra no añade valor a
la sociedad bueno este sistema hace que
se aplane un poco la curva de
rendimiento pero podemos debatir si eso
añade valor a la sociedad nada más
déjame expresar un último punto pues
obviamente todos pensamos a los
banqueros como los campeones del
capitalismo déjame escribirlo por acá
campeones
campeones del capitalismo a menos que
estén por caer en bancarrota son los
primeros que pegan el grito en el cielo
cuando el gobierno se quiere meter o
hacer algunas redes de seguridad pero
irónicamente toda su industria está
basada en una red de seguridad
gubernamental esta idea de intermediario
financiero que dibuje por acá ya sabes
los capitalistas de riesgo y los fondos
de capital privado todos los que operan
de manera similar ninguno de éstos es
dependiente del gobierno federal bueno
puede ser que acabe siendo lo de manera
indirecta pero no necesitan así un
sistema tan sofisticado de intervención
gubernamental como la ventanilla de
descuento y la fdc todas esas cosas no
las necesitan estas instituciones pueden
trabajar sin ningún problema sin
intervención gubernamental incluso este
banco en este banco comercial que pues
tenía estos certificados de depósito en
vez de tener esta media verdad de las
cuentas de cheques de la reserva
fraccionaria incluso el banco puede
operar sin intervención gubernamental
por otro lado este sistema el de la
reserva fraccionaria no podría existir
sin la intervención del gobierno no
puede existir sin la intervención del
gobierno entonces ahí te va una duda
sabrá es una buena duda para debatir o
para pensarla en tu cabeza verdad pero
este sistema este sistema de reserva
fraccionaria que depende del gobierno
que depende del gobierno
está metido en el capitalismo está
metido en el capitalismo o sea ve dónde
está la competencia donde está la
innovación ahora resulta que si eres
suficientemente grande life dice te da
permiso de arbitrar la curva de
rendimiento y te puedes comprar tu reloj
rolex y hacer muchísimos viajes en tu
jet privado yo no veo la innovación
simplemente por haber sido grande y
suertudo obtuviste esta certificación de
life dice te asegura y aquí no hay
innovación y la competencia uff pues si
acaso la persona que toma la mayor
cantidad de riesgos es la que va a
obtener más ganancias y además está
asegurada por si comete errores
vaya van a aparecer los más exitosos
pero en realidad es por un respaldo del
gobierno es nada más por un subsidio
de este modo el dinero que estas
personas están ganando el dinero que
estas personas están ganando viene de un
subsidio federal y por tanto viene de
las personas que pagan impuestos
entonces esencialmente los que pagan
impuestos están subsidiando a este mundo
en el cual se gana dinero sin tomar
riesgos sin invertir en proyectos buenos
y ubicando bien el capital sino
arbitrando la curva de rendimiento con
un seguro barato eso está feo verdad
esencialmente es que hay un cierto
sector de la población que pues
básicamente está extrayendo rentas que
está extrayendo un subsidio de otro
cacho de la población y eso segurito que
no es la parte de nuestro sistema
económico que tiene más necesidad bueno
pero no estoy contando texto para
impugnar el sistema financiero de hecho
creo que en la mayoría de los casos de
estas personas si están tomando el
riesgo y obteniendo un retorno y los
ahorradores de acá saben en qué se están
metiendo sin embargo no hay intervención
del gobierno ni un subsidio
gubernamental por otra parte toda esta
cosa está basada en un subsidio federal
la banca de reserva fraccionaria no
podría existir sin la fdc y la fcc no
podría existir sin pues está suposición
implícita de que el congreso les va a
pagar pues cualquier error que cometan
justo como pasó hace algunos años en
eeuu
bueno espero que esto te ayude un poco
más a hacerte tu propia opinión la
verdad yo no quiero aparentar que soy un
reaccionario loco y en cierto modo ya me
resigné a que el sistema de banca
fraccionaria no va a desaparecer pero si
me molesta un poquito pues depende
completamente de la intervención del
gobierno y tenemos este sistema
económico en el cual estamos apilando
nuestro dinero en estas entidades que
pues no son las más listas sino
simplemente son las que toman más riesgo
y con esto nos tienen la punta de cañón
están en la disposición de osea tienes
que darnos más dinero porque si no lo
haces las cosas se van a poner feas por
nuestros errores y te vamos a llevar con
nosotros